[Music]
mr. Woltz you're welcome dude thank you
sit right there
first of all on behalf of the Congress
and the committee we want to welcome you
to the United States Congress we've I
think everybody's been an admirer of
yours for years we watched you on screen
and the stage and we have really not
only admired your beauty but your acting
skills as well and we're very happy to
have you here today to testify about
nutrition and supplements so if you're
prepared for an opening statement
proceed mr. chairman could I Oh scuse me
pardon me uh mr. Ben Gilman our chairman
of the International Operations
Committee had a brief statement he one
day put it in the records thank you uh
we're conducting a hearing across the
hall on Russian policy and I thank you
for the opportunity I regret I couldn't
be here earlier and I'm I want to
apologize to our witness but I did want
to put in an opening statement passage
of the dietary supplemental health and
education Act of 1994 I think it's
brought about a number of important
improvements for millions of Americans
who regularly consume dietary
supplements to protect and improve their
health
a DSHEA guarantees the right of
Americans to have access to the
traditional supplements the consumers
have used for a number of years and new
products that are just beginning to come
into the market today and DSHEA insures
these new products are safe and properly
labeled for sale in our nation studies
and testimonial statements from
consumers have shown that supplements
can and do improve good health however
the FDA slow acknowledgment of the
benefits of dietary supplements has
brought us here today and without BS HEA
there's no uniform quality of products
and a lack of information about these
kind of supplements that are available
to the public
so once the regulations will be in place
in practice and I'm pleased that the
Commissioner has indeed Jane Henny has
indicated that they're moving in that
direction once they're in place and
practice consumers can be confident the
supplements will be safe and regulated
we must make certain that the FDA
implement
DSHEA is prescribed for any act of 94 so
I'm pleased a new FDA Commissioner is
Jane Hemi has testified here this
morning that she will be dedicated to
help FDA fairly interpret implement and
force' provisions of this act as they
were intended when Congress and this we
passed the act and while some have
argued that DSHEA is full of complex
questions affect policy and law it's a
duty of FDA and its commissioner to
enact this measure and provide the
American consumers with safe and
regulated dietary supplements and I want
to commend our witness Raquel Welch for
coming to us today they give us her
thoughts with regard to these
supplements Thank You mr. chairman
welcome before I yield mr. Welch mr.
Waxman is your Congressman and he would
like to say a word of welcome and I
don't blame him a bit I want to tell you
how pleased I am to be here to hear your
testimony and to welcome you to our
committee hearing I came back from the
vote anxious to hear your testimony and
I'm going to be able to hear it but I
was also able to hear mr. Gilman's
statement as well unfortunately I wanted
to apologize to you I'm not going to be
able to join you and other members for
the lunch after your testimony because I
have the previous engagement with dr.
with Bishop Desmond Tutu from South
Africa but I want to welcome you here
and look forward to your testimony I
hope I'll be able to say so man has some
questions but I disapprove shake your
willingness to come here and tell us
your views Thank You Kim miss Welch well
good morning chairman Burton members of
the committee and a special greeting to
my congressman Henry Waxman of
California
I am Raquel Welch and before I begin I
just like to say that I am NOT a paid
spokesperson for the dietary supplement
industry nor do I have any financial
connections with it I am here today
because of a statement made by former
Surgeon General C everett Koop
who is quoted as saying if you want to
be successful in life
sooo good help I am a woman who has
played many roles an actress a wife a
mother and a person who made a decision
some Oh 25 years ago to take an active
role in maintaining my health and
well-being it has been one of the most
important roles of my life and much like
a demanding role in a film or a play it
requires preparation and study on the
screen and on stage of a pair with a
script if you've chosen to make dietary
supplements part of your life as I have
you prepare but getting information the
available the availability of truthful
balanced information on the dietary
supplement labels is guaranteed now by
the dietary supplement health and
education Act Congress unanimously voted
in favor of the consumers right to know
what dietary supplements are for and how
they work most importantly this
information is mandated to be where
customers can look first on the label
for the past five years customers have
had access to valuable information on
how supplements affect to the structure
and function of the body
these congressionally mandated structure
function statements now appear on
dietary supplement labels allowing
customers like me to make informed
choices
however I've recently been informed by
the National nutritional foods
Association that the FDA has proposed
rules which would severely curtail these
structure functions statements and
therefore restrict the information that
Congress intended these statements to
impart mr. chairman as you well know and
as I have learned structure function
statements must not say that a dietary
supplement is intended to cure treat
prevent or diagnose any disease and a
disclaimer to that effect must appear on
the label in conjunction with any
structure
statement my understanding is that the
FDA that what the FDA proposes is to
expand the definition of disease to the
point that virtually all structural
function statements would be discouraged
or outlawed I know that there are
instances where label statements have
been made beyond the explicit limits
stated in the dietary supplement Act but
I believe that even the FDA records will
show that these claims are found on only
an impetus table number of products
approximately 1% as a consumer it seems
to me that the FDA should use its
enforcement powers to eliminate these
questionable and unsubstantiated claims
that would be understandable and logical
however instead the agency is proposing
virtual elimination of an entire
category of consumer information with
broad restrictions and confusing rules
I'd say that's like killing a flea with
a cannon mr. chairman millions of
consumers like me have and will benefit
from learning more about these
supplements from the structure function
statements what the FDA is proposing
seems like a regulatory sleight of hand
to stifle such statements I implore you
and members of this committee to urge
the FDA to withdraw its proposed rule
the language in the existing dietary
supplement Act already gives sufficient
direction and establishes explicit
limitations on structure function
statements and it gives FDA the
authority it needs to chase down
delinquent companies and their products
the FDA's proposal ignores congressional
intent and flies in the face of the best
interest of the 100 million Americans
who like me take dietary supplements
every day
we need and ask for your help if
health-conscious citizens are to
continue to be able to make informed
health choices it is after all part of
the American Way I've been taking
something new since 1 million years BC
so please support us thank you very much
well I saw 1 million BC and those
supplements really work I gotta tell you
first of all let me thank you for coming
today you represents as you says a lot
of Americans who take supplements among
which I am one and how do you how do you
decide as an individual what supplements
that you should take well um I think I'm
a pretty average Joe in in regard to
that I've I hear that something is
effective and then I try to get the
information about it sometimes you can
work through a distributor who you can
get in touch with personally and they
can explain everything to you and ask
all kinds of questions but most times
you really have to go in I have to go
into a health shop a health and place
where they have all these supplements
and read the labels and decide for
myself what I think is the best thing to
do but I I want to just say briefly
although you didn't ask me that this is
always in conjunction with regular
medical check-ups that are you know
under a doctor's care and everything but
I rely heavily on the labels and on the
individual distributor who can tell me a
lot about these things you don't have to
answer this question but what kind of
supplements do you take to many
dimensions oh I just take I take
supplements every day and I take a wide
variety of multivitamins and I also take
other things that I guess could be
classified as women's supplements like
calcium and and those kind of things and
I also take blue-green algae supplements
what kind of an impact do you think
these supplements have had on your life
well I found very specifically that when
I've tried certain supplements that they
have helped my energy level which I need
when I'm on Broadway for instance last
time I found something new in the way of
a supplement was when I was in rehearsal
for victor/victoria and I found my
energy level you know sort of dropping
lower and lower and I was eating all the
right foods I don't smoke and drink and
as everyone knows I'm pretty much of a
healthy creature and fairly disciplined
but I couldn't I found myself slumping
and actually my brother said to me that
he knew of a distributor that handled
blue green algae products and that they
were very effective in boosting up
energy in a very natural way no caffeine
or anything that revs you up you know
and makes you speed away so I started
taking them and they were very effective
and I've been taking them still I just
have one last question and I think you
may have answered it in your opening
statement that you you do believe the
information that you're getting on these
supplements that you buy in the health
food store is adequate and well enough
labeled I believe they are I would I
would like more information but as
according to what you know the rules and
the laws are now I think that to have
less would be a very bad thing we had
the the Commissioner and just before you
testified and I believe they are going
to try to expand the information on the
labels and and in the product so that
the consumers will even have more
information that was I think that would
be very helpful and when I was growing
up as a young girl there was nothing
like a health food store or a health
store which you could go and get in
vitamins and supplements that was just
not in the mix at all and as I've come
along now this is very much an everyday
thing and everybody I know takes
supplements of one kind or another it's
interesting to note that the next
generation or certainly the generation
that is
you know out there now you know is
conversant with this kind of thing and
they usually hear on the grapevine that
something is working well and they go in
to find out for themselves it would be
better if we had more specific
information I think and more of it of
course there's books that you can get ho
bucks on herbal supplements and vitamins
and what they do because I think most
people now have an attitude about
preventive medicine trying to go to the
doctor on a regular basis but for
treatment only as a last resort if you
can't cure your malady by something that
can help your immune system or to keep
you stronger and more energetic on on a
regular basis so you're not going into
the doctor with all kinds of small fries
stuff that you that really does affect
the quality of your health on an
everyday basis
very good mr. Waxman Thank You mr.
chairman thank you very much for your
testimony you sure right about the idea
that it's only recently we've been
learning so much about the impact of
diet and and and how beneficial some of
these vitamins and supplements can be
and to me the most shocking thing was
that for so many years doctors didn't
even take classes in nutrition and
medical school so we need to educate
everybody about the value of of
nutrition in our diet whether it's from
food products itself or from supplements
that would make up for the lack of some
of the essential nutrients that we need
I think that the stress in modern day
life makes us not absorb some of the
nutrients from our food and that's why
and I think that the new woman if I can
call her that
this last hundred years has been
expanding her horizons so much that her
energy is often taxed and so it's I
think men too
and modern society have this problem so
they try to shore up their resources as
best they can
in a natural way and defense of current
physicians I just say that I guess going
to medical school is a pretty a barrage
of so much in
Meishan that is about really serious
illnesses that it takes a great deal of
time and effort to absorb that and
therefore it's difficult you know
because it isn't in our culture common
knowledge I would think the probably the
next generation of physicians will know
more about this kind of thing I
certainly hope so and I think the
medical schools are trying to adapt and
recognize it the fact that it would
certainly be beneficial for our society
if we can prevent some of these diseases
and not just deal with them after they
occur but in getting the information we
all want accurate information we want to
know what products will be helpful and
which not and I think that sometimes I
get concerned when someone who stands to
make a lot of money wants to tell me how
their product is so good for me and I
want to know that somebody is sort of
watching to be sure that when they make
those claims there's some validity don't
you feel that way - I do feel that way
and I am certainly a supporter of the
FDA and everything that it represents
and all that it does however I do
believe that when we're talking about
herbs and some of these supplements we
are talking about things that haven't
just arrived yesterday only perhaps in
this culture but in other cultures
throughout the world they have been used
for literally hundreds and thousands of
years so there is a kind of a knowledge
if you will that's among kind of a when
I say the word traditional but
historical knowledge of these herbs and
other supplements and vitamins that is
known to people and it isn't I don't
think I don't think it's even advertised
any near as strongly or with as much as
the exploitation value as most of our
other food products are on the market
television and magazines today well
there's a lot more advertising a lot
more on television and newspapers and
magazines for one product or another yes
that's an important thing to look out
for I don't I personally don't think
that we're to that level yet in this
particular dietary supplement area
but we are being delinquent in our
claims that's like is my opinion is well
we passed the bill though some members
advocated that we allow people to say
that their product would cure diseases
and without going through any FDA review
of that and I thought so too so you
don't want to let them say a product
cures diseases yet the function
structure claims can get very close to
saying it cures the disease so it's a
hard line is it's a hard line to draw
what we want the FDA to do is to draw
that line in a way that will get the
information that the public needs to
know without having people deceived and
with claims that that aren't accurate
and that can't be checked out and over
which FDA would have no no I take it
you're in favor of this particular the
regulations a regulation I haven't
looked at them I haven't looked at them
specifically I was in favor of the
structure-function claims and I want
structure-function claims to be
permitted but I don't want disease
claims to go under the guise of a
structure function claim you wouldn't
would you no I wouldn't but I don't know
that their claims as much as they are
information I mean people have to know
well what they're taking it for
information from somebody who's trying
to sell you a product always little
suspicious that's the American Way we're
all selling something well I suppose
that's true but in a lot of times the
consumers are deceived as a result of it
so we want to make sure that when it
comes to your health wouldn't people get
very anxious about it we do live in a
time when there's a lot of anxiety but
we want people to have access to
products that are going to be helpful
not harmful I absolutely agree but I
think that the statute says they stand
now are sufficient guidelines for their
protection for the public the statute
has to be implemented so they have to
decide yes what what the speculations so
they have to top regulations so you
would prefer the draft regulations
differently than what they proposed and
FDA is now considering all the comments
they receive and we'll see what
they come up with but thank you very
much thank you Thank You mr. chairman
miss Welch I am just thrilled that
you're here and and the evidence is in
the package I guess I'd have to say you
you do handle such a tremendous schedule
and and obviously your personage speaks
volumes for our concerns thank you very
much for taking the time out of your
busy schedule to to be here thank you
you know I guess I have the feeling like
most Americans that I really want to
take my own health concerns into my
hands as much as possible and stay
healthy stay energetic ahead of the
power curve of getting sick and then
having to seek medical help and I kind
of want to use an analogy based on what
mr. Waxman said every every morning I
I'd use up my own carrots and celery and
apple and parsley and that's an energy
drinkin very good for him it's full of
vitamin A and other vitamins but I
wouldn't want the federal government
because I drink this juice that is also
sold in health food stores because I
know it gives me energy to tell me
whether or not I can go to the grocery
store who is probably making a small
profit on those carrots that I'm buying
and and you know because of that I still
want to be free to be able to make my
own juice juices or or take my own
supplements and take care of my own body
go ahead of the power curve and I we all
need information about that that's
that's a thing especially the new
generation will be starting out let's
say that there's some young woman or
young man that is and this is of course
totally in agreement with what you're
saying is going to come along and say
you know I want to be healthy I want to
make the best of my life I have this
ambition and I know I'm going to need
optimum health and energy like coop said
you know to make my way in life so you
know I've been told that if I take some
vitamin C I'm not going to
you know I'm not gonna get sick as fast
if I feel the cold coming on these kind
of things will be passed along and
they'll go in and they'll read a label
now if the label doesn't say anything
they're going to be deterred from even
trying because they don't they really
literally don't have any information I
think that we have to have on the labels
things that help people understand it's
up to them whether they take the vitamin
C and they say yeah forget about it you
know this doesn't do a thing for me
you know it's not like we're forcing
people into this to say oh you must do
it I mean a lot of things that some
people take don't work at all for me and
I wouldn't do him I wouldn't have them I
wouldn't buy them or I've returned them
after having bought than his eye you
know this isn't this isn't for me at all
don't you deny but I would thought we
were talking about the same thing thank
you Miss Chynoweth it's really great
honor thank you very much for being here
I reiterate what the committee feels
about your personal experience really
enhancing the implementation of the
dietary supplement health and education
act that this Congress passed you know I
look at I do look at labels of some of
the supplements when I go to a health
food store and I'm always curious about
what they will do and what they will not
do do we as consumers have an obligation
to do studying ORS or other reading to
to help us in the decision-making I
always wonder how much am I supposed to
know when I look at these items in the
health food store how much I don't know
you know I'm not you know an expert on
this I just can speak from my own
personal experience I think short of
making claims to cure and and do
something special for you they just need
to say first of all what they contain
and what they are there but what they
what they do and then I think you have
to be deductive yourself and make your
decision and like so many things in in
this world it does come from trial
Nerra I think we're trying to save
consumers from spending money
unnecessarily or giving them hopes that
are not going to be we have to be
careful of that caveat emptor you know
let's hire these and yet we have an
obligation I guess that's the balance
I'm trying to resolve we have a an
obligation to also look at what we know
about certain products before we
automatically believe what we would like
to have them be able to do well I I
would agree if this was a drug we're
talking about and I and I think that
there but I'm what I'm basically saying
is that I think that there exists
already all the provisions to protect
the consumer I think to go beyond that
is getting is going over the line it is
a fine line but I think it's going over
the line and could possibly inhibit the
taking of these things to people who do
take them now and who will not people
who will not have access to them in the
near future
because it takes a tremendous amount of
time to go through and test so that
speak everything when some of these
things have literally been around if
they've never been seen before but since
most of the men pen around for you know
the beginning of civilization
practically you know it's it's it seems
to me as I said killing a flea with a
cannon I know that there is an
obligation but it's almost like saying
well what will carrots do for you we
should we ban carrots they're not right
for you I mean herbs have been around
for so long I mean you either don't want
carrots oh you do want carrots you know
I'd love to believe what I see and what
I see and I reading it I'm never sure I
mean I grew up with the idea that you
take your carrots be your vision and
fish was for the brain and you know some
of those concepts and and yet I think
there's a certain amount of self
education that's important
it didn't write a new FDA director this
morning talked about her recommendations
for sorry annotation did you hear the
new director sorry I did not hear it her
recommendations for how she was going to
implement this act I'm sorry I did not
I did not mister not aware that she was
making this thing it would be very
interesting to tip for us there would be
our obligation to see how she follows
through on that but I think mr. chairman
the fact that you have this hearing
makes us all very much aware and I think
it helps the FDA to know how Congress
feels and how the citizenry feel and
your being here is as a role model thank
you thank you very much Thank You mr.
chairman thank you Miss uh miss Baker do
you have any comments or questions Thank
You mr. chairman
and as welch when you're talking about
the diet supplements are you talking
about something that might have been you
said this goes back for really centuries
something like things that have been
used by like Native Americans with or
they could be like teas or like roots or
is this part of the dietary supplements
or I don't yes there would be part of
dietary supplements there are a lot of
teas that are very very useful I think
for various functions you know other
thing is is that you know they're not
going to one particular product whatever
it may be that is not a drug is not
going to work the same on each person
you know chamomile tea is supposed to be
calm you down and relax you can take it
before sleep I'm sure this helps many
many people's never helped me but it's
not a bad tea I'm perfectly happy to
have my chamomile tea from time to time
because of the taste some people some
people with caffeine and they can't make
it at night very difficult for me that's
one of the reasons why I mean caffeine
really causes in my body a very decided
reaction that is negative and I can get
terrible migraine headaches from it and
really you know throw my whole nervous
system off which affects other parts of
my body it's not a nice thing so I try
to avoid that so I'm looking for other
ways that I can
actually shore up my energy without
speeding around like the Looney Tunes I
don't like that kind of a thing at all
so it really is what you're saying as
far as finding the right diet the right
nutrition is really the responsibility
of each of us to to find out what works
I think so I think each person as in
everything in life I think that one of
the the beliefs I have is that each one
of us really does have to find in
everything in life what works for them
there are all these things available I
think that to try to take on the
responsibility or what the individual
person has to find for themselves is as
too much to ask of anybody even the
government I think that that we probably
do that what about like with pregnancy I
know that you know years ago everybody
took all the vitamins took everything
and then there was this big thing about
with pregnancy of not using anything
that might be harmful or there was the
discovery that that a lot of these
things do you think that's I'm sure
that's true and yet I'm sure that
pregnant mothers today would probably
take a lot more vitamins they would want
to I've been pregnant many years so I
don't that tell you what they do now I
haven't even fortunately thank you very
much for coming appreciate it Thank You
mr. watcher we are expecting a mr.
kucinich I think he wants to ask just a
few questions before we release you from
the table but I want to assure you that
we'll be watching and working with the
Food and Drug Administration as well as
the people in the industry to make sure
that the structure function rule doesn't
change the intent of the Deshea law is
extremely important I think that the
will of the people expressed through
legislation passed by the Congress be
followed by every bureaucracy in our
government and if we find a bureaucracy
that tries to supersede existing law
that's been passed by the Congress with
a regulation then I think that we need
to hold them
call them to account and we will
certainly do that and I want to thank
you I want to I guess I better yield to
mr. Norton Norton I see at the end of
your question Thank You Sharon it's a
result of hearing losses testimony I
must say that she has inspired some
questions in me
the first is have you ever heard of the
placebo effects yes I think I have isn't
that where somebody takes a substance
and it really doesn't have anything in
it that you're testing and then because
of psychological reasons it seems to
work or not work yeah that's why it's
why we it that's that's I think that's
an adequate you know when we take
something we want it to work and and
we're all human that's why we require
control studies for for medicines
because it would be very dangerous to
rely on the placebo effect and so as a
matter of the scientific method is
understood worldwide we normally do not
rely on anecdotal evidence well the
reason that interestingly you say well
the reason that something may work on me
and not work on you chamomile tea or tea
doesn't make you sleepy to make someone
else sleepy well at some point the world
wants to know whether or not it makes
most people sleepy or only some people
sleepy some of the time the only thing
that serves me right your testimony is
is this notion that despite all that the
scientific method has established for
hundreds of years you seem to believe
that for something as precious as your
body how you receive it should be the
answer even if that may be in fact the
placebo effect and you may be spending
your good money on a placebo well I
don't I don't happen to believe that's
true I know what you're getting at
but I don't know how any study could
help every person know how it's going to
work on them that's impossible and and
no study and I don't want thing to do
that do purport to tell us whether in
the main the claim to effect is valid or
not and I was interested that you said
people do deserve as much information as
possible it isn't that the kind of
information you'd want people to have in
the main recognizing that there are
always some people who die of aspirin
even though most of us get our headaches
cured but in the main I'd want to know
that a very tiny percent die of aspirin
but I'd also want to know whether or not
aspirin cure headaches in the same way
and I speak of somebody who in fact
takes all kinds of these things so
judges for herself like you but the more
I know whether or not somebody who I
trust some scientific expert says it
works the more the more confident I am
that I am taking what is right for me
well and from what I hear you'd want it
I think you would feel better if you
knew if you knew know if you knew that
that somebody you trusted in fact said
that this substance should work this way
as opposed to word-of-mouth telling you
that it works this way
well I can only say that about ten
million Americans feel adequately
informed at this point to take these
supplements regularly and I happen to be
one of them
I respect in your disagreement with me I
would think that for somebody like you
and me who taken brought relying on
what's on the label that what we want
the FDA to do is not it's not failed to
tell us what works and what doesn't work
as a scientific matter what I think we
should be pressing the FDA to do is to
find some way to test these substances
faster so that we have information to
rely on we ought to be pressing
the scientific agency to do its job
rather than saying step back we don't
need you let us simply rely on how this
on what's in our head which may be a
nice thing no now I'm saying rely on
what's that is existing right now in the
FDA in the rules that are existing now
instead of what I understand to be the
idea is to take the definition of
disease and expand it to such a degree
that for instance pregnancy menopause
things like that that what I consider
normal would not be considered normal
and you're expanding the definition of
the word disease to such a degree that
pretty soon you can't say anything I've
heard you use than they the word claimed
and many times I don't I didn't use the
word claimed in my statement today and I
don't believe that the that the the
rules that are in place now the laws
that are in place now talk about any
claim in fact I think it precludes
making any claim so I think we're
talking about something that really is
not I'm not talking along the law is
talking about making a claim the law
doesn't exist as a practical matter
until regulations are issued and yes I
know I'm these technicalities you'll
have to forgive me I'm not to just let
me say that I join you and and your
confidence in many of these substances
and I think the only thing we can say
about the 10 million people is who take
them is that the more information they
have the more confidence they will have
and what they are taking thank you mr.
chairman thank you I'm not sure mr.
Kucinich is gonna make it let me just
end up by saying that I share your
concerns I share your desire for
adequate information about supplements
and I share your concern that we not
allow bureaucracies to supersede the
rule making authority of the Congress of
the United States when it passes a law
that law that to which you referred in
your testimony the dashaee law was
passed overwhelmingly by both the House
and the Senate and for any agency tried
to impose a regulation
that that supersedes the intent of the
law is just wrong and this committee
which oversees the entire federal
government and every agency of the
federal government will exercise its
authority to make sure that the
regulatory agencies adhere to the law
now we'll try to work with them to make
sure that this consumer is protected as
you stated in your statement we're going
to make sure that the law is followed
and toward that end I want to thank you
very very much for being here thank you
celebrity your celebrity not only adds a
great deal to our hearing but it adds a
great deal to to the the American
public's awareness of how important this
issue is and I'm sure people across the
country who may be watching this on
television are going to appreciate you
taking the time out of your busy
schedule to come here and testify and
with that let me just say that we're
going to recess and those who are
panelists or who will be panelists this
afternoon along with miss Welch if you'd
like to join us in the back for a brief
respite where we can have a sandwich to
by deed and maybe talk with her just a
moment I'd really appreciate that and
once again thank you very very much for
being responsive we stand in recess
until about that 1:15 but it took to the
fall of the gavel around 1:00 o'clock